you you've alluded to the fact that
green party members will have to ratify
this deal
can i ask a question that they will want
to know the answer to
and can i ask you each to answer this in
with a yes or no for the sake of clarity
are you against development of the
campbell oil field of shetland
um i think politics and the challenges
we face with the gates of respect jim
demands more than simplistic yes no
answers and again if you don't mind i
will answer questions in my own words
not in the words that others invite me
uh to use um i set out my position on
campbell last week i suspect the
green colleague my green colleagues here
will set out the the view that greens
have expressed as well i do think and
this agreement recognises that that
there are significant questions um about
whether
in the face of the code red climate
emergency we should be continuing with
unlimited fossil fuel extraction and i
think that's a question that people
across at scotland and indeed the world
are asking and therefore i set out to
the prime minister powers over this
still lie with the uk government not my
choice that is the constitutional
reality that in cases of fields like
campbell where licences were granted uh
many years ago two decades ago in that
case but have not uh yet started
production there should be a
reassessment of licences against a
climate test in the same way that new
licenses will be subjected to the the
climate test and we've got to accelerate
the transition away from fossil fuels
which is some of what the steps in this
agreement
sets out and you know clearly we have
differing views to some extent um on the
role of oil and gas but we have an
agreement that we must accelerate that
transition to net zero and that's what
we are determined to do
it's not simplistic it's a red light as
to whether or not you are you oppose
developing the cambodia
if you can't say you're against it why
should they trust you i think green
party members are perfectly and smp
members are perfectly capable of
listening to what i see and hearing what
i see i set out last week that i do
think there is a significant question
over at the continuation of developing
new fields and therefore i have asked
those who hold the power uh to look
carefully at that um and that is the
position i take and i think people can
understand that even if i don't use a
simplistic language that you're inviting
me to use lorna i want to reiterate the
first minister what the press minister
has said about this not being a devolved
matter this isn't something that we are
going to be able to decide
and implement
in in scotland but what i can say is
that i i'd like to acknowledge the the
first minister's
direction on this that she has has made
i think a significant change in
direction on her approach to oil and gas
with the statement that she's put out
last week and
this is a big step in the right
direction the scottish greens are
unequivocally against cambo but our
hands are tied while we're not an
independent country and we just don't
have those powers so we will continue to
work to try and get those powers to do
what the scottish greens think needs to
be done
patrick yeah i mean i would just add
that yes of course greens oppose
campbell
and uh have long
challenged the idea that uh you know
ongoing
maximum economic extraction can be
compatible with the
uh the response of the the global
climate emergency but i do want to
recognize that the first minister has
changed position on this that's really
important and i don't think that's the
end of the story because i think every
political party across the spectrum is
going to have to change long-held
possessions
on the oil and gas industry we need to
do that in a way that invests in the
communities that are currently dependent
on that industry gives them a real
economic prospect for the future
and hope rather than simply uh the the
fear that can come with with the
prospect of change and this deal does
include serious investment uh for the
communities uh that would be affected uh
both in terms of of transition
technologies
and other forms of investment as well so
there's there's a great deal to be
optimistic about in this agreement as we
commit ourselves to rapidly
transitioning that transition has to be
just and it has to be fast and that's
what this agreement says
500 million pounds transition deal for
the northeast of scotland and murray is
set out in this agreement let me take
the opportunity today to challenge the
uk government to match that so that we
can accelerate
that transition it must be a transition
that is just for jobs for communities
also to make sure that as we reduce
reliance on fossil fuel we don't
increase our reliance on importing
fossil fuels but this agreement is
serious about making sure that
transition is just but also that it
happens at a pace that is necessary to
protect our planet